previously on the forest oh the wing is
gone is that bad
do you see a man standing over my son
right now melon bar
melon bar we need to find a place to
live
let's go down by the beach yeah i like
the sound of the beach i know there's a
good beach the beach i'm talking about
has like a boat that you can go out to
i'm placing the shelf here my dudes wait
have you found the turtles in the water
yet
mark and i have only constructed an
entire fortress in the time it's taken
you to get one turtle shell all right
morning time to go back and get some
more turtle shells what if we made an
adventure out let's go all three ghosts
we can get three turtle shells and we
can explore the boat while we're there
and get all the goodies on the boat
so here's the house that's by the beach
no
they might have some good goodies oh god
hello people
uh guys uh guys uh guys uh guys
you all right oh well you know this is
friendlies
okay yeah i'm gonna go now oh he's on
all fours
oh no yeah hey look bro he's he's
goleming at me i don't know if i like
that yeah bros and let's get out of here
bro
when when they come at you on all fours
with the wow
you and molly get to the hotel looking
at each other in the eyes all dreamy
she she goes to the bathroom and does
her 80 000 bobby pins from her hair
comes back out on all fours
and that's when wade knew it was on look
uh
way down i don't want to write i don't
know there's no
boat here i may have miscalculated where
i went
i didn't listen i don't know where i
just trusted
well i mean it seems like just the way
that we were exploring no it's
definitely this way i don't want to
disagree with you but i think that it's
good don't i'm going this way all right
everyone split up
i'll see you in hell i'll go inland and
hope that the beach somehow moved inland
see you in hell that's my i delivered
that line
that's my line i'll see you in hell oh
come on bro
i'll see you in hell where will you see
me hello
deeper i'll see you in there deeper
deeper yeah that's the stuff
i thought you're just gonna keep doing
it until mark's voice exploded
i mean he would just stop i think if i
pushed it too far so
it gets so low that you wouldn't be able
to hear it oh
hey friend did you find more people i
found some more
friendly friendly people uh they seem to
be leaving me alone in large part
so i guess that's fine good what is it
watch oh my god he jumped over me yeah
thank god you got such hops that's you
got you can jump far dude
did you guys find the beach because i
don't see a beach over here
uh no boats yet sir but i'm 100
confident there will be a boat
yeah right if i am swimming in boats oh
look i found a stack of five turtles
over here they were all just
[ __ ] they're what
you ever seen turtles go at it no no i'm
the only time in their entire life that
they're fast if you know what i mean
that's unfortunate because that's the
one time you wouldn't want to be i
relate to this conversation
oh my god this tree is getting blown
dude i found the
boat i told you it was this way
i don't think so if you found the boat
then i found
other turtle beach i've got like eight
turtles in my inventory right now
i found the boat
that didn't work right i found the
wow language mister all right where are
these turtle shells oh hi
hi wade i i mean assuming it stays there
should be one further down the beach
that i was able to carry
do you just have to murder the turtles
is that it yeah
aim for their head not for the shell
believe it or not
i i that would have been my instinct
yeah oh hey mark you want to murder this
turtle no you got it man
you want to become one of the turtle
slammers you got the turtles oh god
mark there's so many come help me you
slam them with me
no no you got a man you're turtle
slammer master
play queen slay there are so many coming
in to die yeah we only carry one shell
at a time but if you want to murder them
all you can
i'm trying are they people in that water
like turtles they would be really sad if
we did
so we should oh
do you get to eat the good parts of the
turtle or do you yeah yeah yeah you
could just take them
yeah yeah okay good because turtles are
delicious
all right mark and i are going to the
boat we're going to the boat you're just
not going to touch that one
look i haven't eaten turtles okay i'm
just assuming uh
you know i didn't actually hear the full
i was actually invited to eat turtle one
time
because i went fishing with my dad and
we caught a big old snapping turtle the
person the
person who owned the land was like oh
yeah we'll make a turtle soup out of it
and
we all did not want any of that that
seems kind of messed up
i mean i guess maybe snapping turtles
are kind of a nuisance but like
i don't know if i would eat a turtle
yeah not my not my cup of turtle oh hey
that
uh whatever your name is there's a
picture on this cabinet is this a bob
son
no no that's a bear that's a teddy bear
guys i know you've got a lot of turtles
but let me just say
i've been equally if not more successful
all right unlike you guys questioning my
success and finding this turtle beach
originally i've never questioned you bob
there's a keypad here what does a turtle
look like
am i missing them it like shell
head flippers we need a um an access
card or something to get into the back
of this boat this boat has a secret
lair yeah well more like the captain's
cabin with
something i've got more circuit boards
than i can carry
so well that's good there is stuff to
make with the circuit board i'm pretty
sure but i just can't remember what it
is
wait do you see bob anywhere i don't see
his name
i'm over here where's here uh
yeah i'm sort of like waiting left of
our house oh i see him
he's as far away as possible okay i'm
coming back i'm going to the house
i'm going i'm going to the house i'm
going to get a melon bar and then i'm
going to go
ben for such an enormous island it
really is
kind of empty feeling except for the
rocks man [ __ ]
yeah there are lots of rocks if rocks
were edible we'd be set
well i think i found the queen the one
her majesty
she's very pretty the queen mark over
here to your right queen
he's head and shoulders above the rest
are you guys back at the house or nah no
no way
oh a cave mark look at this good it's a
cave
go ahead ma'am you're in that game
no we could i did not like caveman bob
whispering in my ear like that
[Laughter]
this is my favorite of the things i've
heard and i haven't learned about the
galactic
sorry i yelled right into the mic i'm in
trouble
ow i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i'm
gonna die i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die wait are you helping me actually
gonna die i'm gonna die wait are you
helping me
they're stopped they stopped at a rock
you're good you're in the clear okay i'm
in the clear
you distract them with that rock they
really like pride rock oh now they're
after me
good good good good to know i'm still
the smartest okay
you're gonna help me oh god mark please
come back for waiting man no can do
buddy
no can do spill baby though owie
i see the fortress guys i'm bad i made
it home we're almost showing them too
okay we got turtle shells oh hey hello
need to make more water collectors
i can't wait to see the two that are
already built
bam i can't wait to get spine in my
water
oh my god i'm cooking a whole lizard i
like how you're so ready to just stab
that
fire or anything that walks in front of
you god
oh i put it down okay
there we go oh look at all these water
collectors we did
i put it over there there's already a
whole lizard on there that apparently
you only eat chunks of oh my god there's
so much meat on the fire right now
oh yeah but what are these rocks for
what are these mark oh is this the sauce
sos yes oh five builds
collectors built this in a bush that
makes it that better
yeah there you go you know what i'm
proud of you thanks man hey mark where's
the trap
uh it's over here oh there's nothing in
it though
what the what an ineffective trap well
there's a rock in it give me that
do we have any next steps on survival i
think we've basically done the entire
book of survival all right cool
i could build a garden we could try
gardening or a drying rack
whoa dead fall trap we should garden
what about deadfall trip
happy birthday trap happy
[Laughter]
it's birthday a terrible idea i bet this
feels like a bad idea
whatever you're doing i'm on board okay
all right man
so i could apparently only put big meat
i can't put fish on a drink
mark look at you that makes sense i love
these
uh mark what was the inspiration for
this trap at outdoor style
i call it the happy birthday trap pretty
self-explanatory
happy birthday okay happy birthday
we're probably gonna get attacked
tonight by the way well then it's good
we've got so many birthday traps going
on yeah yeah
okay do not go
what exactly does this do i'm thinking
we should be awake
we can walk around it we can definitely
walk oh i see what it does
yeah yeah yeah this feels like a thing
you definitely should walk on
no it's fancy easily it's totally safe
it's only safe
collector nothing bad will happen all
right wade we need you to come over here
and we need to explain something to you
yeah wait be safe please come over here
all right
be careful coming over here all right if
you hear us yell happy birthday
do not come running through this door in
a straight line okay
what's the point of um not safe is it
this first stick
yeah no you should you should test it
then you should test it if you want to
understand what's going to happen you
should test it
you should test this well i'd hate to
ruin your guy's contraption no it could
be reset it's
it can be reset yeah it's reusable yeah
it's reusable
happy i'm curious if i'll take any
damage oh i will
oh my god
happy birthday happy birthday
to you oh you need another stick when
that happens
just one stick that's it you just got to
reset the trap stick bro
i'm standing on the drafts birthday did
you fix it oh okay good
hell that's a cheap reset that's a hell
of a i was where i was standing i took
about one third damage
oh oh you took damage too oh shoot i did
yeah okay
good duly noted it's got nice range and
it's raining we're water collectors
um does anybody know how to make
bandages
if you put a couple rags in the middle
and then right click on it
it'll show you rope molotov
bone armor sorry i can't hear you over
the storm
if you just mouse over the cog on the
crafting thing
okay that well okay i tried to make a
bandage i made a mullet of cocktail
[Laughter]
wait i can make stealth armor what
i made i made stealth armor i don't know
how that works out but
hell yeah i'm happy for you what are you
using to make is it the lizard
i think it's the lizard skin yeah that's
pretty cool though guys i can make small
rock bag what does that do that's good
small rocks are used for the slingshot
that none of us have made all the extra
small
rocks
oh wait i'm freezing to death oh the
trap
hey um there's a trap on this
mark can you reset your trap yeah well
hang on i just
got rid of all my sticks i gotta go get
more sticks i'm not
saying that i triggered the trap and it
hurt me
i assume that man but it needs to be
reset
so say no more i would love
how do you get your health back up if
it's not from eating meds
medicine i've got lots of booze
yeah that's medicine i've got one meds
oh [ __ ]
me wait are you on fire right now it's
raining so no i didn't stay on fire this
time
oh guys i hear some voices in the woods
happy birthday okay eating does give
some help
okay i'm resetting the trap very cold
i'm
very cold very cold i need to sit by the
would you like to sleep this cold rainy
night away i'm just sitting by the fire
hey buddy oh my god hey you feel safe i
feel safe
i feel safe people thanks wade you're
sitting the wrong way
last time i sat the right way when i
went to get up i lit myself on fire so
oh well that is a problem it's like a
design flaw
ah nice fine it's just a challenge there
you go man isn't this nice
i'm just i'm yeah i'm just very fearful
of standing again
i just i don't want to stand up yeah
it's fine it's fine do we also be
pressing c
to save do we all have to save or just
one of us i don't know man i'll save
let's see what happens
oh i can save in a slot well i'm hungry
again
oh this lizard oh the meat can spoil i
didn't know that
oh they spoil yeah oh [ __ ] you guys want
spoiled meat
might as well eat them up you can cook
probably just won't be as good all right
so you're taking the first one that same
size
put one on there before you guys came
over oh okay sure sure
i did i did i totally sure sure
all right oh a bird was just on my hand
and i decided to eat so he was just in
front of me for a second
what are these for what are oh stick
racks
yeah so i'm just gonna there's a drying
rack and a garden over here this drying
rack if you get like lizard meat i think
you can hang it up it'll last longer
oh we should have blueberry seeds dude
what do i need to do definitely how you
plant them you can make a we can plant
things we should definitely dry the meat
because
then it's preserved and that's probably
how you carry it around will those just
grow do we need to like water that or
something
i have no idea it looks like they're
growing because if you look at yours the
ones you just put in they're just like
yeah
they're different yeah
well i also have blueberry stuff yeah
planet bruh planted
what is that under is that custom
building it's under food
the fish symbol apparently there's a
food ah food okay rabbit cage water
collector drying rack garden
oh you can have a live rabbit do they
make new
rabbits can we get a little rabbit
voyeurism going on over here well i
didn't know you're right i'm gonna make
some rock holders
over by your stick holders it's fine
mark i'm gonna gloss over that
yeah i am gonna gloss over that calm
down okay
i'm calm down
almost ran into the trap because i'm a
freaking idiot
myself preservation monetary very high
so i will not be running through that
door ever again
oh god damn it i pressed w instead of e
did you actually i went on fire again
my stick sucks
i'm safe preservation
that's what you sound like i deserve
this i'm hanging up a lizard to dry
can i hang up a deer if i kill a deer
uh yes oh yeah what's the dude doing
he's just letting me kill him he's
taking it yeah he thinks he can he
thinks he could take it
damn that deer maybe he can okay got him
that was the saddest thing i've watched
today okay rock holders are also
finished stick holders are
loading them up well then i'm about to
yeah i'm about to have a full load of
stick
reno's for you my dude hell yeah i'll go
get some more rocks
oh i should have taken some heads oh
wait never turn down head that's what
mom always said
yeah that's what mom always said mama
always said mama always said that
never trust a fart never down down head
and never waste a boner
yeah it makes sense i get it look at all
of our resources
i know right i never play games like
this
i i i relate to that expression of
feeling
very deeply and strongly it's just
absolutely
uh complete opposite of what normal
gameplay is like it's nice
we were prepared we knew it was
difficult and we were up to the task
are we though uh i mean we haven't
really been worrying about weapons armor
i got armor i got sneaky armor so you do
have sneaky armor
did you guys ever get the the fuel i
have
one gas can on me use the fuel the
chainsaw is description
where do we get a chainsaw yeah where do
we get a chainsaw
that's what i want to know all right
well the stick holders are empty but the
rock holders are full
who took all the sticks i'm building
more log holes
over here all right you're right you're
right i've i've never lived in such
luxury mark
a bone chair i want mark to have a bone
chair
thank you man could call it his bone
thrown
yeah oh a large raft guys we could play
raft
in the forest oh [ __ ] dude oh yeah do
you care about your child at all
we should be wearing oh yeah yeah no
dude let's let's live it up a little bit
before we worry about that dumbass
i just wanted to hear you say it kids
are so annoying am i right
yeah i thought it was me it was him the
whole time
i've been having such a good time since
we lost him
tragically or whatever i don't know i
[ __ ] hate that dude
yeah no i was gonna say your kid looks
like just uh the worst kind of person
that's an
absolute garbage human am i right yeah
yeah yeah
f tier really f tier yeah god can we
rank humans
dude can we do a human tearless human
yes yeah
yeah that's what you want stuff to do
yeah hey there's a guy over here with a
skull on a stick
tell you about that guy uh is he nice or
oh it doesn't seem nice don't worry bob
i'll come help you
we'll take him out i need his skull
anyway oh he has a friend his friend
doesn't have a skull how hard do you
think it is to kill a human
oh that's she's got
boobs she's got what oh my god that guy
skull boy once shot me almost wait
there's like a whole group of them
i thought you were helping but you left
hey happy
don't let me down now happy birthday do
they cross
water do we know about this find out i
think they lose your scent
oh they're over there look at them
looking at us you want a piece of this
that's right you were afraid of this
cake all right wade
who's afraid of cake yes i found a
lizard i now have more skin for my
collection
i don't like that wait i just put lizard
armor on my hand
that's not good i wanted to craft it oh
bob i see your stealth armor recipe what
is that is it
sleeves uh yeah it's literally just
lizard and leaves i think
i'm so stealthy right now guys i'm
sneaking through their camp
i think i'm gonna find their leader take
him out and then we'll be rid of them
forever
is one piece of stealth armor enough or
do we need multiple pieces
it's do we need me i've got one hand to
come
you guys can get up to ten i think oh
i'm pretty
i'm feeling pretty sneaky here guys i
think i'm good
wait is is stealth bob okay can you see
him where you are right now
hey wait i got you a skull that looks
like a trap maybe i should
walk over that he's doing well mark he's
doing well good it sounds like he's
doing well it sounds like he's really
doing it um well
i'm gonna escalate it i don't know um
you all right um
um lizard distract the blizzard
power of the lizard bob you're so
stealth i can't even really see you so i
gotta ask how much stealth armor are you
wearing
uh one piece schmunk
don't worry i have five arrows i'm
basically untouchable
schwonk right in your dick okay maybe i
shouldn't take this fight this might be
a mistake
huh you're all right it's fine it's fine
it's fine you're not
wait why is there a herd of them uh
happy birthday protocol
what have you done are they chasing you
where did those come from i heard of
them just came from the direction of our
home
our home no i'm literally just hunting
lizards i've had no contact with
anything bad
it's fine it's fine stealth armor
engaged
sneaking armor oh there's more how many
are there what happened did i trigger a
trap card or something what is this
i heard them scream just now yeah it
might be hard mode
bob you should get back mark we should
uh happy birthday i'm coming i'm coming
don't worry
i'm not seeing anybody following you
they would be following me if they could
which they can't i'm fine
that's fine i think the stealth armor
could not have worked better yeah
definitely man i don't even see you i
blend in
so well i know at some point they do uh
start yoloing out of the woods they'll
never find our camp
so should i make another hello hello
birthday uh
on the one of these other should we
every entrance probably
we probably yeah should do that yeah
that's probably prudent
yeah okay okay hello hello birthdays are
there like torches
yeah uh we get a little cloth no like
like oh like structural torches for like
illumination
uh that's a good question oh i made you
a like i found you a skull do you want a
skull
bone chandelier okay well i'd like to
have that
i must have the bone chandelier i would
enjoy
the fire i think it's the standing fire
would be the torch i'm gonna make a
couple of these bad boys
fyi there's gonna be a trap outside this
door so don't come
back which door now no no no not this
one right
not the look you just guess which door
and you're gonna find out man
hmm there we go look at that happy
birthday
i'll make another little torturino over
here
do you guys want to sleep the night away
again
do they attack us if we sleep or are we
like you didn't tell me you finished my
trap i almost just walked
oh
[Laughter]
wait i didn't finish your trap i'm doing
my own stuff did you finish your own
trap and not realize it
yes i did not finish it i went to get
the last pieces
sure sure i'm the truth you are
the truth i am truth in korean is sashi
and you are sash i am the true you can't
handle this
are there footsteps around us or is that
just the birds fly i've been hearing
footsteps but i just i have no idea nah
dude we are right we are right
i'm gonna equip my spear no reason
that's a torch yeah
that seems like a bad you guys want to
sleep yeah oh no i ate spoiled food
is this one spoiled mark what are you
doing you know you eat right now you're
just going to lose it all as you sleep
this is this one's boiling should wait
till i wait if i were you i would
they were all spoiled someone's really
going at it out there
wait what was that i think we might be
getting under the attack we should sleep
immediately
happy birthday it's not gonna make him
go away i don't think he's gonna make
him go away
oh well they they're like oh they're
sleeping we'll come back later they're
very respectful about it
well i guess we'll find out also i just
want to point out
in what world are adult-sized humans
fitting under this shelter that we so
haphazardly
constructed oh yeah oh yeah man what do
we sleep in the fetal position
on the hard dirt oh dude
well you seem to be all right aside from
the fact that i'm hungry
yeah i'm hungry too what happened all
the food i ate yesterday oh hey these
are these blueberries are done though
if you guys are thirsty we could drink
we need these blueberries and replant
i'm all right are these fully matured i
don't know i would guess though because
they have the e symbol yeah i'm guessing
this the berries will pop back on here
when they're done
we should plant a bunch of these we
should make more these are great
yeah dude bears are suffering they're
very cheap four logs
four logs four logs just nothing that's
nothing
can we reposition wild blubberies don't
you have to eat them get the seeds from
them
and then just make a blueberry blue oh
did i get did i get seeds oh yeah i
totally got one blueberry seeds guys
come over where i'm at there's a bunch
of blueberry bushes come top
up nom nom away let's get some blueberry
seeds let's get some planters
i got three blueberry bush seeds i have
eight
i have eight seeds dude let's get so
many planters right now
marigolds oh marigolds are good if you
see yellow flowers that you can harvest
marigolds are good for uh healing they
make healing stuff
we need marigolds and uh aloe if you
don't need sticks and you stab the stick
bushes
it actually gives you a lot more leaves
than normal leaf piles too it seems
oh oh you can just make the plant as big
as you want
oh oh can you like draw the planter on
the ground yeah apparently what the hell
oh [ __ ] dude let's get some giant
planters i'm going big i'm going big
i'm going big there's marigold over here
gathering this little
mini forest yeah yeah over by over by
the oh yeah
still just needs four logs it's four
logs no matter how big you make it
apparently yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
friend aren't we bros who's who's bro
this lizard skin i want to wear oh my
god i don't want to be your bro
bros let other bros wear their skin
i'm telling you bro bro come on bro
come on my god i this blender's so big
it can fit five by five in here 25. hell
yes dude oh i like it i currently have
four
blueberry seeds dude our outside bush is
gonna be loaded
dude our blueberry bushes are gonna keep
us through them we [ __ ]
bloobed out of our minds dude i am
already bloomed out of my mind
guys look how much freaking meat we got
going on over here
do we have to cook meat to get health
from it because eating my health is not
freaking a yoink am i right
yeah how do we get bone whoa
you all right forgot about the trap that
i walked right into literally
thank god it's not just me can i just
say that
you okay i lost one of my armors
oh that's unfortunate yes it was all
right well
have a good day yes or more i guess i
didn't get as much
oh yeah
oh yoink
whoa jesus man was that aimed at me
ow you broke another armor pieces oh
sorry
dammit i'm sorry if i'm gonna get this
bird
done bird's done can i not heal while
i'm wearing
armor why can't i eat healthy that
wouldn't make any sense
i have the tiniest little dick of health
and it can't
someone please clip that but cut it
before he said i'm healthy and the
tiniest little dick there you go
that's easier yeah why is one and two
eat and drink
that makes no sense what are the
controls at all on this actually
walkie-talkie do we have a walkie-talkie
oh
whoa i just heard you yeah are you guys
talking in game hey what's up why are we
doing this
hello man in game voice
it seems so obvious do you have to press
something once you're
no it's just open it's just open mic
oh boy which makes me wonder why
it's not like that when we're near each
other just talking but i'm putting it
away
like proximity voice yeah are you saying
proximity voice
yeah it's so obvious it's so obvious
now anyway i'm going to try to slingshot
one of these dudes because i want their
bones
wait i can drink water from this little
pond what
oh it's not guys i'm dying
oh good well i'm glad that i'm glad we
did that
are you actually dead oh my god
how much did you try to drink
i wasn't even trying to drink i was
trying to eat the berries oh
okay yeah all right oh i'm dead i'm dead
dead
oh oh wait where are you back on the
plane
oh what the hell did you lose all your
stuff how did you drown
exactly by drinking the water from i
went to drink yeah well i went to eat
the berries
and then my face was like oh go
face-first into the water
well yes i will you must have drank it
through your windpipe
and i didn't even spawn on my bed what's
the point of having the [ __ ] beds
we didn't have a bed you can build a bed
but you didn't have a bed well we have a
shelter in it like a bed did you hit the
save button yeah
and i don't know what to tell you man oh
my god guys i'm catching fish
oh dude you can catch fish in this game
oh hell yeah
no there's nude hey mark
what's up bub is it are you close to
here you know what i'm not gonna ask
questions it's fine it'll be fine
i'm gonna destroy these dudes
[Music]
you